lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
analizar por qué tiene sentido que dos
compañías creen un duopolio
polio
para coordinarse o llegar a un acuerdo
que podría o no ser legal probablemente
no sea legal y restringir la cantidad y
también veremos por qué cualquiera de
estas dos compañías tendría el incentivo
de hacer trampa con nuestro trozo
acuerdo y producir más cantidad de la
cantidad que acordaron producir digamos
que nuestros dos jugadores en este
duopolio esto se aplica al oligopolio en
general pero su análisis será un poquito
más difícil si el que tuviéramos más de
dos jugadores pero digamos que ambas
compañías son idénticas ambas tienen un
costo marginal que luce algo así
esta es una curva de costo marginal y
ambas tienen una curva de costo promedio
que luce algo así una curva de costo
total promedio que se ve así curva de
costo total promedio y eso es idéntico
en ambas compañías ahora veamos cómo
lucen las curvas del mercado vamos a
elegir arbitrariamente un valor del
costo marginal esto es lo que produciría
una compañía con este costo marginal
pero si tuviéramos las dos compañías se
podría producir el doble de esta
cantidad así que se llegaría aquí en
este costo marginal
las dos compañías estarían por acá si
eligiéramos este costo marginal una de
las compañías podría llegar a este punto
de acá pero como son dos compañías pues
ambas producirían el doble con este
mismo costo marginal se produciría el
doble lo que se hace es esencialmente
cuando se tienen dos compañías iguales
es que tendríamos el doble de lo que
marca esta curva en el eje horizontal
así que este sería el doble de esta
curva de costo marginal la curva para el
costo marginal de las dos empresas así
que lo voy a indicar así aquí en
amarillo con una línea punteada más o
menos
como diría la curva de costo marginal de
las dos empresas así que esta es el
costo marginal
para el mercado
en este ejemplo el mercado se refiere a
estas dos empresas y lo mismo se va a
aplicar para el costo total promedio si
el costo marginal se encuentra aquí
entonces el costo total promedio de una
empresa estaría aquí pero si se trata de
las dos empresas se duplica esta
cantidad así que tendríamos que las dos
empresas estarían aquí con respecto a su
costo total promedio va a lucir el doble
de ancho que la curva para una que la
curva del costo total promedio para una
sola empresa así que con la misma lógica
vamos a dibujar cómo quedaría la curva
del costo total promedio para el mercado
son menos
así que esta es la curva del costo total
promedio
para él
mercado
así que la convención que he estado
usando es este color salmón para el
costo marginal y el costo total promedio
de una sola empresa y esta línea
punteada amarilla para las curvas
correspondientes al mercado ahora
tratemos de encontrar cuál sería el
precio correcto si ambas empresas
pudieran coordinarse y esencialmente
combinar ambas empresas para que casi se
comporten como un monopolio y para
encontrar esto vamos a tener que dibujar
la curva de demanda imaginemos que la
curva de demanda del mercado es luce
algo más o menos así esta es la curva
de demanda
del mercado
así que estas dos firmas o estas dos
empresas cooperan trabajan juntas y si
dibuje la curva de demanda del mercado
también tengo que dibujar la curva del
costo de ingreso marginal y recordemos
que ambas empresas están actuando juntas
se coordinan perfectamente de manera que
unan sus capacidades y se comporten
esencialmente como un monopolio si es
que actúan como un monopolio la curva
del costo de ingreso marginal tendrá el
doble de pendiente que esa curva de
demanda del mercado esta otra curva
tocará el eje aproximadamente a la mitad
de manera que lucirá así
esta es la curva de el ingreso marginal
del mercado
este sería el costo total promedio de
las empresas actuando como monopolio y
esta sería la curva del ingreso marginal
si esto se comporta como un monopolio la
cantidad óptima se encontraría justo
donde el costo marginal es igual a el
ingreso marginal antes de este punto no
conviene producir ya que el ingreso
marginal es mayor que el costo marginal
y después de este punto no quieren
producir ya que el costo marginal va a
ser mayor que el ingreso marginal y
tendrán pérdidas económicas en cada una
de estas unidades incrementales así que
esta es la cantidad que ellos quieren
producir y el precio que se debe de
tener para esta cantidad de acuerdo con
la curva de demanda del mercado
esta es la curva aquí así que el precio
que tendrá está más o menos por acá y
digamos que el costo promedio por unidad
aquí tenemos que ir a donde está el
costo total promedio para el mercado
en este punto este es el costo total
promedio por unidad así que la ganancia
económica promedio por unidad será el
ingreso por unidad menos el costo por
unidad así que esta altura es la
ganancia promedio por unidad y si
multiplicamos esto por la cantidad total
de unidades obtendríamos la ganancia
económica total
de estas dos empresas coordinadas que
esencialmente se están comportando como
un monopolio y simplemente para
continuar con la discusión digamos que
esta altura de aquí es de 10 y la
cantidad que ellos quieren producir como
monopolio es de 50
cuál será la ganancia económica total
aquí pues su ganancia total económica
será de 500 la ganancia
ganancia
económica económica
total
de estas empresas que se comportan
conjuntamente como un monopolio es de
500 esto es si se coordina
coordinadas
así que las empresas ven esto y dicen
oye pues por qué no nos ponemos de
acuerdo y cada uno de nosotros produce
la mitad de esta cantidad y después nos
dividimos la ganancia económica y para
ver esto digamos que una de las empresas
accede a esta empresa decide producir 25
a esta cantidad le va a corresponder
este precio de aquí y su costo va a
estar justo acá eso es para cada empresa
individual lo que tiene sentido ya que
este costo es el doble de este costo de
acá aunque en la gráfica no se note
exactamente y recordemos que esta línea
punteada amarilla de aquí es el doble
del costo total promedio de lo que sería
para cada empresa individual así que
cada empresa obtendrá esta ganancia
económica promedio por unidad
multiplicada por el número de unidades
que queramos eran 25 unidades así que
esta será la ganancia económica promedio
que recibirá cada una de las empresas o
la mitad de estos 500 o lo que es lo
mismo 250
por empresa
ahora pensemos en la razón de por qué
hay un incentivo para que una de las
empresas o ambas empresas hagan trampas
digamos que una de las empresas en
particular la otra respeta el acuerdo
que tuvieron pero la otra empresa en
lugar de producir 25 unidades dice bueno
me gusta este precio de hecho estoy
teniendo ganancias económicas vamos a
producir 10 unidades más así que esta
otra empresa dice bueno yo no voy a
producir 25 voy a producir 10 más voy a
producir 35 unidades y si esta empresa
produce 35 unidades y la otra empresa
continúa produciendo las 25 del acuerdo
entonces la producción total en lugar de
50 será de 60 la producción total del
mercado será de 60 y ahora cuál será la
ganancia económica total pues vamos
subimos de aquí hasta la curva
de demanda del mercado caemos aquí el
nuevo precio estará
más o menos por acá el costo por unidad
estará aquí y el número de unidades que
se están produciendo es de 60 así que
tenemos esto la nueva ganancia económica
va a ser ésta
área
de acá que estoy señalando en blanco
esta área
y aquí vemos que con este cambio la
curva de demanda y el costo total
promedio están más cercanos así que
digamos que esta altura de acá es de 8
así que serán 8 dólares de ganancia
promedio por unidad x 60 unidades así
que cuando uno hace trampa
pongamos aquí el caso en el que se hace
trampa
separemos esto del caso en el que se
coordina y respetan su acuerdo así que
ahora tenemos 60 unidades de todo el
mercado multiplicado por 8 dólares de
ganancia promedio por unidad tendremos
en este caso una ganancia
económica
total
d
y 480 aquí nuestra ganancia económica
total disminuyó lo cual tiene sentido ya
que ahora como mercado se está
produciendo más allá del punto ideal o
el punto de equilibrio en donde el
ingreso marginal es igual al costo
marginal ahora el costo marginal del
mercado está más arriba que el ingreso
marginal así que todo esto de acá
esencialmente está creando una pérdida
económica ya que cada una de estas
unidades incrementales en el mercado
están ocasionando un costo mayor y como
el ingreso marginal está más bajo que el
costo marginal pues estamos creando aquí
una pérdida por eso es que nuestra
ganancia económica total bajó de 500 a
480 pero cuánto va a ganar esta empresa
que está haciendo trampa bueno esta
empresa tramposa está produciendo 35
unidades 35 unidades
o menos por aquí 35 unidades y una
ganancia económica de 8 dólares por
unidad
así que tendrá de ganancia toda esta
área en verde que estoy señalando aquí
así que ahora hagamos la multiplicación
de 35 por 8 me voy a hacerla aquí en
esta esquina 35 por 8 8 por 5 44 8 por 3
24 4 28 así que la empresa tramposa la
tramposa
está teniendo una ganancia económica
total de 280 dólares y la empresa que no
está haciendo trampas digamos la que es
el compañero honesto
con esto honesta la empresa honesta
entre comillas ya que de todas manera lo
que están haciendo no es legal el tratar
de coordinarse entre las dos para
producir una cantidad fija no es legal y
bueno creo que mejor le llamo la que no
hace trampa vamos a quitar esto
la empresa no tramposa
no tramposa
va a tener el balance de la ganancia
económica así que si la ganancia
económica total es de 480 y la empresa
tramposa ganó 280 xm fue un cero
entonces el resto de la ganancia va para
la empresa que no he hecho trampa que es
de 200 así que vemos que en efecto la
empresa tramposa se beneficia al
producir más cantidad de la acordada ya
que pasó de tener una ganancia de 250 a
280 así que para esta empresa esto sí
tuvo sentido y si vemos la empresa que
no hizo trampa si le afectó muchísimo
esto porque de tener una ganancia de 250
pasó a tener una ganancia de 200